we often have this sense that the world
is depending on us that we were born
into this world for a specific purpose
that we must accomplish and contribute
to some bigger story that everything we
do is incredibly important however if we
took a moment to look down at the dirt
and up at the stars with a little
examination we quickly realize that we
barely have any idea what we are looking
at and that perhaps we are wrong in our
feeling that we are fundamentally
important to anything beyond ourselves
as humans we are merely a blink in the
universe's seemingly indiscernible story
we live on a tiny wet rock rotating
around a star in a single part of a
single galaxy in a group of other
galaxies amongst thousands of other
groups of galaxies known as galaxy
clusters and the galaxy cluster we are
in is amongst thousands of more clusters
all of which make up what we believe to
be the universe something so large and
perplexing the human brain can't even
comprehend any of what was just said
based on science this whole universe
thing started 13.7 billion years ago
expanding out of the Big Bang it is also
believed that from this moment right now
the universe will continue for some more
billions of years and then its energy
will burn out and everything will end in
what science is coining the big freeze
the strangest part in all of this is
that we don't even know if any of what
we think we know is true in any case it
is fair to argue that if any of this is
even close to true essentially nothing
we do in our life matters to anything
beyond ourselves that we are an
insignificant and mean
be strung along by an indifferent
universe that cares very little about
our opinions hopes accomplishments and
failures the idea that we are not
important and that nothing we do matters
to anything beyond us might sound
upsetting and disappointing at first
however it is incredibly liberating our
common delusion that we know what we are
doing and why we are doing it that
illusion that what we do will matter to
the universe or some discernible bigger
story this delusion brings on a level of
anxiety guilt and pressure that can
never be satiated an unnecessary and
never-ending need to achieve higher and
higher levels of things regardless of
what is good for us or what we truly
want to do with our life in recognizing
everyone's fundamental unimportance and
the absurdity of everything the weight
of the universe slides off our shoulders
the pressure of needing to do anything
specific or to live life any certain way
releases from our consciousness
realizing this does not suggest that we
should just give up and sit on the couch
and do nothing it does however suggest
that we can and should intentionally
choose what we wish to do with our lives
and not succumb to any social or
psychological pressure to live any other
way
ironically the beauty of living on a
planet in a universe where we don't
matter much if at all is that if there
is no inherent meaning to our life we
get to decide what means what to us we
get to decide how we want to live
therefore we must examine deeply and
patiently into ourselves and discover
what it is we wish to do with our life
not what the universe wishes to do with
it not what other people wish to do with
but what we wish to do with it despite
what our psychology and culture might
often try to convince us we don't
necessarily need to pursue the highest
position in our career field we don't
necessarily need to scale our business
we don't necessarily need to become
world famous for our art we can do or
try to do these things if we want but we
must honestly consider how these things
will affect our lives before deciding if
we want to do them and in the process
also realize that if we do or don't do
them
we remain just as important and
unimportant as anyone else there is only
one reason to do anything instead of
nothing in life it is not wealth fame
status or power it is finding a sense of
energy connection expression and
enjoyment in the action of doing the
things we choose to do life is far more
flexible to our wishes than we often
think so long as we are willing to make
the right sacrifices for many of us we
can live life how we would like to in
order to do so though we must emit any
and all of the extra nonsense that
people have told us is important but
isn't to us and find what is important
to us and do that in the end so long as
you find financial comfort so long as
you feel engaged in your life and so
long as you aren't harming anybody along
the way you've done as much as anyone
can ever do and you can stop feeling
guilty about needing to do more whenever
you'd like
[Music]
thank you for watching if he found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder